Hãy dịch quân sự kéo dài từ ngày 18, sau đến 20,000 tương tương sống dưới xoên ràng và yên ràng đã khiến hai bên dưới và tình trạng tiêu hào nạn này, cả về quân sự kinh tế và sấu ấy.
Bình yên đồng tấn công qua lại linh tục, cả hai nước đường trực thị thải nghiêm trọng, tạo ra sự kế, mùa hợp phải chấp nhận thật thận bắn dọt tổng mý đường nân trạm để xuất.
Thuy nhất, Isterrain Tuyên bố phá huy hàng loạt cơ sở quân sự quý văn và làm suy yếu nước lực phòng thuộc của đối phương, nhưng lại không thể phá huy cơ sởa mian chế lực phó đầu.
Châu khi đó, Isterrain đã phóng hơn 5 chem tên lừa và nghe in ua vay và lãnh thổ Isterrain, gây tổn thất đáng tế về dân sự và kéo cân lưỡi phòng không của nước này.
Thưa hai, tình hình tình tế của cả hai bên cũng chú anh hưởng năng này.
Ibran phải đối mặt với làm phát và nguy cơ bắt đầu hình của sáo hội sau khi kết tơ sở năng lượng bị cân công.
Isterrain dù có nền kinh tế bứng cũng tư tốn hàng tìm đồ là Mỹ trở phòng thuộc và chính sĩ quân sự.
Cái nhà phân tích cảnh báo, nếu xung lộ tế tổng, hai cua ra sẽ dưới và tình trạm suy kiện một lực nghiêm trọng.
Thuy bà, chú sơ gái tự tộng đồng cuối tế và phá lưỡi tư tự trọng nước, lãnh đạo cả hai bên, mùa phải tạo dựng trị sử.
Cái seren và ibran đều tuyên bố, zang đừng những thành khoảng nhân định, sống dưới quản xác cho rằng đây chỉ là sự luy bước chiến phật trong một cuộc đối động chua có hội kết.